[Music]
[Applause]
I had this set up a couple of minutes
ago and I thought it was great it was a
big lead-in to Trevor Lawrence this was
the touchdown pass uh against the Ravens
fires toward the right corner of the end
zone that ball is caught caught good
good from a touchdown to the right
corner of the
how good is that touchdown Jacksonville
Marvin Jones Jr
spring and Trevor Lawrence have you
heard that call yet
this is my first time I'm hearing it
with all the guys in here so it's pretty
sweet uh take me into the Huddle when
you start that drive
anything different said
yeah I mean just honestly the two drives
before that you know we were down
um what 19 to 10 on the second to last
drive and just told the guys hey we've
been here before you know we've been in
this situation you know a few weeks ago
against the Raiders we were down 17
nothing early in the game and had to
come back and win that game so just told
them we've been there before nobody
panicked and
um put together I mean we had to
overcome a lot on that second to last
drive to get it within a score and then
you know get the turnover kick a field
goal we're up by one and then they go
down and score leave us like two minutes
then we gotta go do it again and there
was just no Panic you know all the guys
it's like it's time to you know it's
time to time to show we can do do you
have two place called when you go to the
line of scrimmage
mostly well I mean not typically in you
know two minute you're usually going
fast and you're rolling especially if
the ball's in bounds but other than that
yeah a lot of times especially third
down
um specialty passes where you need a
certain look you know we'll have a we'll
have a kill if they're not showing us
what we need
um so we had a lot of those this past I
mean Raven's got a good defense so they
did a good job it was tough tough to run
the ball against those guys that's a
Philly play that you guys ran
which one the Philly Folly is that uh
did you guys you know did Doug what's
the name of that play I thought that
there was something that Doug brought
some of the the touchdown or the the
two-point conversion oh the two points
no it's not well yeah they they ran in
Philly yeah but it's uh I don't want to
get the name of it but they're in it in
Philly and it's a compliment off another
play that you know we actually haven't
ran this season so it was funny that it
ended up working to win the game for us
it's not called the Philly Folly though
you don't want to give away the day okay
it's not it's not that though no it's
not that okay how much of a role did you
play in let's go for two
honestly you know I was sitting over
there and they were talking I had you
know the press in my I had pressed in my
headset talking about the different
situations if we didn't get the
touchdown you know if they reversed it
what are our next couple plays shots at
the end zone so I was thinking about
that I didn't know for sure if it was a
touchdown or not at the time so I was
thinking about that situation and then
you know Doug was like hey it's
touchdown and I looked I was like what
are you thinking he's like I think we're
gonna go for two and win the game and
that's our Right Guard Brandon Sheriff
before that was like let's go for two
like he's screaming he's screaming at
coach and Coach is like hold on I said
hold on a second and then he was like
all right let's go let's do it so that's
what's cool it's just the trust and
everyone's on the same page like we're
not going into overtime we're gonna go
win it right now and
um it's cool to to see everybody just
trust each other like that the
difference in celebrating a win when you
were at Clemson and a difference now in
Jacksonville is what
I mean I think I've just over the past
two years you you know I winning is all
is always great and that the fun is in
the winning is what coach Sweeney used
to say and when I was at Clemson but you
know I don't know if I appreciate it as
much as I do now just because we've won
so much and you didn't have to you don't
have to play as as well as perfect as in
sync as you do in the NFL to win so I
think now you know I've come to
appreciate it so much more and just
understanding what it takes and you look
at that game we win by one point and
there's so many little plays that guys
had to make to to win that game for us
and uh this is a cool feeling when you
especially when you when you drive down
the field and go you take have the go
ahead touchdown or go ahead two-point
conversion to win it with like 14
seconds left that was that was a first
for me in my career and uh for this team
this season that was special but also
you go from a program where you're
always winning and then like you never
want to get used to losing it's great to
get used to winning but how does that
work though when you win all the time
then all of a sudden it's like I I'm not
used to reacting this way or having
these thoughts about explaining why we
lost a game
yeah I mean it's uh it's different it
was definitely a an eye-opener for me in
the past year and a half
of just like you said you know I've lost
two games when we were in when I was at
Clemson in college so in three years and
um then on the flip side of that the
last year and a half having to deal with
with those losses a lot a lot of close
losses
um a lot of games where I didn't play
well you got to stand up there and you
got to just kind of own everything and
that's that's just my that's my job at
the end of the day is whatever happens I
could play great if we lose it doesn't
really matter it didn't do enough to win
so that's just the nature of the Beast
and you know like you said though you
never want to get used to that you don't
never want to get used to losing I don't
think we ever did here you know we had
kind of a we've had you know a rough
month in October really we lost five
straight outside of that and we've been
playing pretty good Ball but obviously
that was that was big as you know we
lost much of those games in a row but
the guys here never got never got used
to that you know never eased up never
started to point the finger I think
that's what happens a lot when you have
a team that you lose a bunch of games in
a row
um it's easy for guys to start kind of
looking around to fight find someone to
bail them out and at the end of the day
it's us you know we gotta we gotta fix
it ourselves how are you different than
a year ago
me or or as a team you
I just you know I think with my
experience I look at things a little bit
differently you know I can see the big
picture
um even just where we're at in the
season you know we're four and seven
obviously not a great record and we've
we've put ourselves in this in this
position but
really there's still everything out in
front of us we we still control our own
destiny you know if we if we go win all
these games we're making the playoffs
and you know and you can't do that until
you win the first one and that was
yesterday but and that's how we
approached these last seven games after
the buy was this is a new season seven
game season and let's see where we stack
up at the end but I just feel like the
confidence that I'm playing with that
our offense is playing with right now is
um is the best it's been all season I
really feel like we're clicking so I
feel like that's a big difference in
right now and where we were a year ago
um for sure he's Trevor Lawrence he
threw for 321 yesterday three TDS in the
win against the Ravens why is there
still this fascination of Urban Meyer
when he was your coach that I'm gonna
guess when you sit down to do these
interviews you're still answering for
Urban Meyer
ah I mean it wasn't just a I think a
unique a unique uh situation that
everyone kind of had eyes on and
everybody was talking about it
especially with how some of the drama
unfolded at the end of the season and
then you know even just being here in
the building it was it was it was a
different situation and I think everyone
was really interested in that and
obviously how it affected our team and
you know I'm start it's starting to die
down a little bit but yeah you still
hear you still get the questions people
ask me
um but not as much as I used to but
definitely it's still it's still going
around at least I didn't lead the
interview with the question yeah no I
appreciate that appreciate that talk
about the game we won now that's great
yeah yeah does Doug Peterson remind you
that he was a quarterback in the NFL
he doesn't have to just the way he
carries himself the way he but he didn't
want to go out and throw the football
and you know he's like not really I
don't think I don't think don't I hope
he hopefully he doesn't watch this but I
don't think he moves the way he used to
so
it's not like he moved like he was Lamar
Jackson when he played yes yeah that's
true that's true no he's uh but just the
way he the way he communicates you know
what is at his longest run from uh
scrimmage was
no you do you have the stat what is it I
think I have 19 yards
19 and and that's long for him
considering yeah I mean I'm old enough
to have watched him play Trevor I'm just
saying I need to go back and watch his
his highlights there aren't any
highlights there's not anything there's
no he's holding a clipboard and wearing
a visor that's that's his highlight give
me the uh that moment where you watch
the opposing quarterback almost as if
you were a fan did you have you had that
moment in the NFL where you're you might
you should be thinking about your
offense but you kind of look out and you
go wow
uh
uh not not necessarily you know there's
a lot of guys that I that I respect the
way they play I think you look at the
the guys that are obviously have Tom
Brady Aaron Rodgers or guys that have
played for a long time and you know I
haven't played either one of those guys
but the guys that I have played are
younger you know only a few years older
than me Patrick Josh Allen Lamar
um there's there's probably more that
I'm leaving out but those are guys that
are so I didn't grow up watching
necessarily but I have a lot of respect
for them because ever since I've been in
whatever it is you know senior in high
school through college I've watched them
so I don't necessarily watch as like a
fan but it's one of those those are the
games where you know as an offense the
challenge that you're gonna have because
no matter how good your defense is
you're not going to be able to stop
those guys every series they're going to
make plays they're going to score
um and I mean even Lamar some of the
some of the scrambles he had yesterday
you're sitting there like you know just
banging your head against the wall it's
like what do you even what do you even
do against that you know guys just
running around everybody it's like we
contain them and somehow he gets out of
it so those guys are going to make plays
and that's the that's just how this game
is and uh it's it's fun watching those
guys but at the same time it's not it's
not fun because you're the team that's
playing them but Mahomes makes it look
easy Trevor it's not easy no he's he's
he's uh he's a special player he's got a
great feel for obviously he's a really
smart player I think is is one thing
that not a lot of people talk about but
the some of the stuff he does but then
also his feel for the pocket and just
creating space you know it seems like
he's sitting back there all day because
he just knows how to maneuver in the
pocket he's he's awesome they got they
got something good going to Kansas City
for sure
wait a minute is that your analysis of
the Kansas City Chiefs they got
something special come on the hot hot
take right yeah wow that's gonna make
some headlines there uh were you a
Falcons fan growing up
not really you know I didn't really
watch much NFL football I would say if I
wasn't if I was a fan of a team it would
have been the Falcons but I was more of
a I grew up watching college football
that was with my family that was what we
were all about so that's that's what I
spent most of my time doing you know
Peyton Manning was my favorite player so
I would watch you know some of the
Broncos games and all that but
um not as much not as much NFL what was
it like meeting Peyton the first time
it was cool yeah we I mean that's a guy
I've looked up to my family is huge
Tennessee fans I was born in Knoxville
so I mean we've liked Peyton Manning and
I've been a fan since I was a since I
was a baby since I could even walk
um so getting to meet him and now we're
actually in the same marketing agency so
we've crossed paths multiple times even
last season I talked to him just get
some advice from him obviously he had a
similar rookie season just ups and downs
some struggles so I talked to him and he
got some great insight and it's cool to
be able to build that relationship now
and you know as a kid I would never
thought that would be that would happen
wait how did the Vols not sign you
well it was an interesting time in
Tennessee football
um I think at that point it was
they had a couple different head coaches
it was it was Butch Jones was the one
that recruited me yeah
um so I ended up they were they were up
there but I ended up not not assigned to
do that they hadn't turned the corner
yet you should you should be a senator
you know that you've you've got some you
guys say that politically correct like
you know what to say you know you're not
going to be overly critical you just you
know you say nice things hey it's uh
trying to throw anybody under the bus
over here no no but that doesn't make
for good you know talk radio just saying
I know that's that's what I said to our
media our media people here I'm like you
guys probably hate when I come up here
I'm like a I'm like a broken record you
guys don't get anything to write any
articles about I'm never in the
headlines
it's okay I'm fine with it yeah I'm I'm
fine with it too yeah hey uh congrats on
the win yesterday thanks for joining us
as always we appreciate it I appreciate
you Dan thank you man thank you Trevor
Lawrence Jags quarterback and uh three
for 321 three touchdowns and win against
the Rams